[Music]
this episode and others like it are made
possible by the generous support of my
patrons on patreon
if you'd like to help me produce more
content like this and get early access
to every new video
consider becoming a patron at
patreon.com second thought
can you trust the media it's a common
question and one that's popping up more
and more often in our increasingly
polarized world
over the years we've seen numerous
examples of news networks twisting the
truth to fit a certain narrative
or spreading outright lies in order to
gain public support for military
initiatives
today with more news at our fingertips
than ever before
it's important to really consider the
question can you trust the media
so in this episode that's what we're
going to discuss renowned academic and
social critic noam chomsky once said
he who controls the media controls the
minds of the public in manufacturing
consent his work explaining the failure
of capitalism and corporate control of
the us
he focuses on highlighting the role that
the media has played for decades and
continues to play
in manipulating public opinion for the
benefit of private interests
in today's climate it's not hard to find
people who denounce the mainstream media
as a pile of lies and fabrications but
then run to fox news or other such
networks as a reliable source of
information
not realizing that whomever they listen
to all modern news outlets are
controlled by a set of interests that
have nothing to do with sharing useful
educational or trustworthy information
just 21 companies own all the media
outlets in the us
five of which own all the major news
networks of the country
you might remember from one of my
earlier videos that these big five are
comcast
disney news corp national amusements and
at t
this quasi-monopoly allows those who own
these companies to feed the nation a
twisted version of reality
and make people believe whatever they
want us to believe this creates an
environment in which only the news that
fits the interest of the individuals who
own these private companies makes it to
the public
this corporate domination of the media
goes hand in hand with the corporate
domination of the government and
perpetuates a system where absurdly
wealthy individuals run the show without
ever needing to be elected
there's a common opinion among many
americans that the media
is entirely the domain of liberal elites
that is not the case
far from being controlled by coastal
liberals trying to paint all
conservatives as racist and homophobic
the mainstream media is controlled by
the same overarching interest groups as
supposedly alternative media like fox
and voice of america
all modern news sources have become a
single unified front aimed at
manufacturing consent and steering the
conversation away from real news
and towards pointless aesthetic
disagreements those who own the networks
may want to appear to espouse different
views
but at the end of the day they're all
staunchly capitalist and benefit from
the same tax cuts as every other rich
business mogul
but since they have to maintain a veneer
of objectivity we get news networks that
fight over petty cultural squabbles
while quietly agreeing on all the big
stuff
the news you see today has very little
to do with informing you about what is
going on around the world in a clear and
objective manner
today's news outlets only focus on two
things pandering to the biases of their
audience
and indirectly promoting the financial
agendas of specific industries
for most of its existence the american
media has painted our way of life as the
best way of life
whether for its economic opportunity for
right-leaning media or
standards of democracy and fairness for
left-leaning media we have been fed the
lie that america is the number one
country in the world and
indoctrinated to believe it the only
thing america can truly claim the number
one spot for is wasting money on the
military
and how do we justify that just turn on
the news
for decades the u.s media has created
new stories to glorify intervention in
foreign countries
often lying outright about certain
events the tiny number of terror attacks
on american soil are covered from all
angles
but the vast and ongoing devastation
wrought in the middle east by the us
military and our murderous sanctions
barely get a mention
and the media doesn't only avoid
mentioning u.s interventions
it also avoids those of its friends and
allies in the 1970s when indonesia
invaded east timor and occupied neutral
territory killing thousands
the media said nothing indonesia was a
u.s ally
today the conflict in yemen has been
labeled as one of the world's worst
humanitarian crises
and it's been going on for six years
innocent people are dying in atrocious
conditions every single day
have you seen any media coverage of this
lately has fox cnn msnbc
abc or any of the others said anything
about the plight of the yemeni people
lately
no why is that because the saudi army is
largely responsible for the murders
and who arms the saudi army the united
states
once again corporate interests and the
country's bottom line supersede the
right to accurate information
no matter which way these outlets lean
they are all
guilty of filtering the information we
receive to suit the interest of their
owners
private ownership of the media has
turned information into a commodity
not a right and commodities have a value
which can be turned into profit
the name of the game in american media
is not to inform engage and empower the
world
as cnn so eloquently puts it but to sell
manipulate and turn a profit for
shareholders
like anything information is a good that
can be sold to the highest bidder
and corporations are willing to pay a
lot of money to get the information they
want in front of your eyes
it doesn't matter if you think all
immigrants are criminals or if you think
trump should be impeached three or four
more times
there's a network out there which has
some information to sell you and it
knows exactly how to do so
polarization in modern media is not
diversity it is not choice
it is simply a blatant abuse of human
nature we all like to hear things that
we agree with
the name for this phenomenon is
confirmation bias if i think socialism
is a conspiracy to destroy america i'll
turn on the news channel that agrees
with me and reinforces my belief
which frankly is all of them but fox
tends to use that line most effectively
the american media has mastered the art
of pandering to its audience
and will continue to do so indefinitely
as long as it helps to turn a profit
it doesn't matter if what they are
saying is even remotely close to the
truth
to make matters worse the american
obsession with free speech has created a
media ecosystem where corporate
mouthpieces can say whatever they want
asserting their unalienable right to
spew meticulously crafted propaganda
into millions of households
despite the fact that the first
amendment does not apply to news
networks
our obsessive fixation on being able to
say whatever we want
regardless of truthfulness has given
news anchors an excuse to lie outright
these days free speech means nothing
more than i can say whatever i want and
promote it as the truth to whoever is
willing to listen to me
this perversion of what free speech
really means has removed any and all
accountability from the media to base
their claims in factual truth
anyone can now go ahead and say whatever
they want on air as long as it generates
more revenue to the channel
that's the bottom line if it brings in
more viewers
if it's profitable it's the truth the
best example of this is the way that
panels are constructed to debate topics
on air
for decades human-caused climate change
has been established as fact
and over 97 of experts agree it's
happening
so why is it that every news panel
contains as many experts on the matter
who accurately report the evidence of
climate change as irrelevant grifters
who do not
this is not to offer unbiased news it is
intended to muddy the water so that
people continue to doubt established
science
human-induced climate change does not
suit the interest of the hugely powerful
oil
gas automotive cruise dairy and meat
lobbies
so they make sure that the media gives
as much attention to nonsense as it does
to fact
the most damning bit of evidence when it
comes to climate change coverage is the
fact that exxon
one of the largest polluters on the
planet was one of the first to conduct
extensive studies on the effects of
fossil fuel use
their internal documents revealed that
they knew just how bad the problem would
become
and instead of working with policymakers
to find a solution
they buried their findings and launched
a decades-long disinformation campaign
to keep the public in the dark
when you see climate debates on tv be
aware that you're watching an ongoing
oil and gas lobby crusade to maintain
their profits
at the expense of the survivability of
the planet and the future of our species
would you find it normal if any time a
nasa scientist is interviewed
to talk about say progress on mars there
was a flat earther there to contrast
views
of course not that would be a waste of
time and would only serve to dilute the
facts presented by the expert in an
effort to sow doubt
that's exactly what news networks are
for not to inform
but to obfuscate to prolong the
profitability of damaging industries as
long as possible
to bring in views by making people angry
or afraid
we are a long way from what reliable
media is supposed to look like
there is no such thing as a trustworthy
news channel or honest media outlet
you cannot trust the media however that
does not mean that everything they say
is a waste of time and you should only
believe what fits your views
that path only leads to further division
and the destruction of trust among the
people what it does mean is that you
must recognize that what you're watching
and listening to has a corporate agenda
that you are being sold a pre-packaged
world view not provided reliable
information
in the world of corporate news outlets
if the information is free
you are the product as products we have
value to those who finance and
manipulate the media
we are pawns for them to use in
forwarding their agenda so long as they
can manipulate our views and manufacture
our consent
the individuals who own the media are
not so foolish as to promote their
views in the open they select the right
thinking personnel editors
journalists and cia wannabes like
anderson cooper and tucker carlson
and they set the priorities of each
outlet to create the narrative that will
make people agree with whatever it is
they want agreed to
western media is a well-oiled propaganda
machine that uses a variety of
techniques to manipulate opinion
it is not a news source yes sometimes a
news anchor or editor will present the
public with a more honest version of
events even if it goes against the
narrative of the channel
they usually quit the next day and go
work for another corporate network
but that is just part of how a good
propaganda machine works
it allows for some descent every once in
a while but make sure that enough of its
core message floods the airtime so that
we get the illusion of diverse and
honest coverage
while gobbling up the lies we're meant
to believe why is this neo-liberal
ideology so dominant in the developed
world
not because it makes good economic or
social sense but because by its very
nature it opened up the media to private
ownership
which in turn now declares that pure
capitalism and neoliberal policy are the
only way for society not to collapse
into chaos
it's a never-ending cycle corrupt policy
enabled the corruption of the press
which now enables more corruption of
policy
and on and on power is held by
corporations who steer the state
which then returns more power to
corporations and both use the media to
tell a story that preserves the status
quo
the modern media is the ideal tool for
effectively and subtly spreading
ideological messages to the public
all you need is money and this corporate
tool is working as intended and
incredibly efficiently
so efficiently in fact that a growing
number of people honestly believe that
the best way to improve our situation is
to oppose
the mainstream and liberals this
fabrication has given rise to a
completely fake anti-establishment
movement run by the elites and fueled by
the media
the global rise in popularity of crooked
politicians like donald trump
jair bolsonaro and nigel farage has been
facilitated by the lies of supposedly
alternative
mostly right-wing media these outlets
financed by the wealthy elite have
worked hard at selling the lie that by
voting for these people
we are supporting someone like us a man
of the people
someone who understands that is a
complete lie
there is nothing like us about these
people they are part of the elite
they've simply decided to try a new
approach to further divide us and
strengthen their hold and that of their
ultra wealthy friends on society
nowhere is there a better example of
this than on fox news
where news anchor tucker carlson
continues to rail against the
establishment
blame immigrants and claim to be just
like his viewers his message is simple
and fits perfectly with his audience's
bias
they agree wholeheartedly and reinforce
their views every day
thinking that they're being provided
real information by someone just like
them
tucker carlson gets paid 10 million
dollars a year to spout venomous lies on
tv
he rails against the elites while being
the heir to a frozen food fortune built
on the back of abusive immigrant labor
he is not a man of the people he sits
firmly at the table of the elites and
uses populist rhetoric to manipulate his
audience and make sure that the status
quo is preserved so that his giant bank
account continues to fatten
the bottom line is this the media is one
giant propaganda machine
fueled by the wealthy for the wealthy
all with the support of a
corporate-controlled state
news outlets are doing an incredible job
of keeping the population divided and at
odds with each other over frivolous
nonsense so that no meaningful change
can ever take place and the status quo
that makes the rich richer is maintained
our media fits perfectly into a
framework of neoliberal hegemony and not
a word that comes out of their mouths
deviates from that mission
the best thing we can do is to recognize
this fact and attempt to understand
others and their biases
as well as recognizing our own if we
truly want to overcome the mind control
operation of the elites
then we need to stop listening to them
and start listening to each other
i mentioned at the beginning of this
video that this kind of content is made
possible by my patrons on patreon
this kind of video while very important
is something that sponsors won't touch
in order to pay the bills and keep this
channel running i rely on adsense
revenue sponsors
and donations from generous viewers by
producing content like this
i lose out on both sponsors and adsense
if you enjoy the kind of videos i'm
producing and you're able to chip in
even a dollar a month i would greatly
appreciate the support
you can find my patreon page join our
growing discord server and get early
access to every episode at patreon.com
second thought if you enjoyed this video
consider dropping a like
if you hated it a thumbs down you can
check out my previous episodes by
clicking the links on your screen
thanks for watching and i'll see you
next week
you